And before we start discussing philosophy and the human soul.
Thous Vani has two words.
Hi,
are you excited as I am?
[inaudible]
it's wonderful to have a this forum here.
I'm so excited to actually started with a dinner.
We had enough Atlanta and the idea of bringing a Dave and Jordan Peterson here,
uh,
came about and actually happen.
So I'm just going to introduce,
not take too much time of the people standing here.
Oh,
sitting here,
sorry.
I'll start with Jordan Peterson.
Dr. Peterson is a professor at the University of Toronto,
was nominated for the prestigious Levinson teaching prize when he was a
professor at Harvard and he's regarded by his current University of Toronto
students and colleagues as one to three truly life changing teachers.
Dr. Peterson is prominent,
prominent intellect,
international speaker and a public personality.
Dave Ruben.
Mr Ruben is a talk show host comedian and a TV personality is the host of the
Rubin report.
I talk show about big ideas and free speech.
Dave has been heralded for his purse.
Eight,
a politically incorrect and honest approach to discussing complex issues and
current events focusing on politics,
religion,
and the media.
Doctor,
you're on.
Brook is the chairman of the board of the Rhine Institute and uh,
he's the core author with Don Watkins of the pursuit of wealth equally is unfair
and there at national best seller of Free Market Revolution 2012.
He is the host of the Aaron Brooks show on blog talk radio and uh,
Greg [inaudible].
Dr Sell,
Mary teaches philosophy at Rutgers Rutgers university and he's a fellow at the
anthem foundation for objective is scholarships and coast security of the iron
ranch society.
He's a co editor of the companion to iron rand in the Blackwell companion to
philosophy series.
Welcome those four and one word about,
uh,
the person who made it possible.
Uh,
uh,
generous board member over the Iron Rhine Institute.
And thank you too.
Hi grout.
Sorry.
High road productions for making this happen.
So here we go.
[inaudible].
So first off to begin,
we are live streaming this on my channel and as I'm sure many of you guys saw,
I was on Joe Rogan's show a couple of weeks ago and we talked a little bit about
objectivism and he said that you guys are very serious people,
that you're,
you're very serious people.
So I need you guys to go absolutely bananas for the thousands and ultimately
hundreds of thousands of people that will be watching this at home.
Can you make some noise?
[inaudible]
they look at you guys.
You crazy.
Objectivists alright,
you're searching when you're such a negative influence.
Dave ask.
I've never seen her like this last time.
Last time I did an event with you guys,
we had the whole audience screaming out George Carlin's seven dirty workout.
That's true.
I don't know if we're going to do that now.
Okay,
so we're going to do about an hour and a half with you guys and we're going to
throw in some Q.
And.
A.
It's obviously completely,
yeah,
sensory.
Then in the free route,
spirit of free speech and individuality that you guys are talking about here at
this conference.
Uh,
so Jordan,
we've been on tour now for almost two months and we have a little break right
now,
but I thought why don't we just dive right back into all the things we've been
talking about.
So much of your,
your tour for your 12 rules for life book has been about the role of the
individual.
So before we get to deepen into philosophy and some of the other things,
I thought that would be the right place to start cause that's sort of what
unifies all four of us up here.
Yeah.
Well I've been making case,
I suppose,
or,
or developing the argument,
and this is an argument everybody knows to some degree,
although I don't think we've done a very good job of articulating it,
um,
over the last few decades that,
you know,
it's,
it's no secret that our free societies or the free societies of the world are
predicated on the idea of the sovereign individual.
Right.
And that's,
that's the,
that's the place where political power ultimately resides.
Or let's say political authority,
but,
and it's also in some sense the derivation source of the idea of rights.
The fact that the individual is sovereign,
the individual has inalienable rights.
And we talk a lot about rights in our society,
way too much as far as I'm concerned.
Not that they're not important,
but they're secondary because the fundamental,
uh,
issue of import with regards to individual sovereignty isn't rights.
It's responsibility.
I mean,
first of all,
you could make a case that your rights are my responsibility and vice versa.
So,
so there's a parallelism between rights and responsibility.
But even more importantly,
if the integrity of the state is dependent on the integrity of the individual,
and,
and that's the argument that's implicit in the idea that the individual is
sovereign,
then it's obviously the case that the individual has a great responsibility.
It's a responsibility that's incorrect,
incredible importance because it's not just limited to you,
it's,
it's you,
you acting responsibly actually constitutes the bedrock of the state.
And so,
so that's an interesting issue.
It,
it means that you're required in some sense to take responsibility or the entire
state will shake.
And I think that's true for everyone,
but more interestingly,
I think this is a more interesting argument in some senses that you need meaning
to sustain you through life or you need meaning perhaps not app,
meaning you need meaning to sustain you through life because life is bitterly
difficult and um,
and,
and ultimately challenging,
moderately challenging for that matter.
And you need a meeting to sustain you through that so that it doesn't embitter
you and turn you into a victim,
let's say.
And it's pretty obvious to me and I think obvious to anyone when they think it
through that virtually everything that you derive genuine meaning from,
and I mean the kind of meaning that will sustain you when times are difficult.
I don't mean casual happiness,
even though there's nothing wrong with happiness.
What the,
the meaning that will sustain you through the tragedy of life is always to be
found in the adoption of responsibility and the people that you admire
spontaneously.
And I don't think there's an exception to this unless you're a little on the
psychopathic side.
And I mean that technically,
um,
you,
you feel,
I do.
I mean,
I mean it technically it's like a,
it's a hallmark of psychopathy.
I would say generally speaking,
you admire yourself to the degree that you do when you're at least taking care
of yourself
at least that and maybe when you have a little responsibility leftover for your
family and maybe some does spill over for the broader community.
And certainly the people that you spontaneously admire in your,
in your fellow man are people who at minimum our accounting further for the
burden of themselves at minimum that,
but then who have excess capacity and devote that to the proper care of their
family and their community.
And so I don't think that we've done a good job of laying out the meaning equals
responsibility,
uh,
equation.
And it's vitally important.
And I think it's very helpful for people to learn that.
Lots of people have told me that,
that,
that you know,
that they've been getting their lives together and digging them out of a cells
out of a nihilistic and hopeless hole.
And doing that by understanding that the meaning they need to sustain them is to
be found through the adoption of the maximal responsibility they can sustain.
And so well,
that's,
that's become clearer to me over the course of these last,
let's say 50 lectures.
So Greg,
I saw you nodding along there a lot.
Can you put some of this within an objective as spring?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
not to plug,
but I gave a talk at actually the event that I met you at called taking
responsibility for your happiness.
Um,
I think I have a bit of a different view of happiness than you do.
And the and ran has different than you than you do.
Um,
what I mean by happiness isn't the transient joy,
your emotion you could feel in a moment,
but the state of being,
the state of emotion that comes from accomplishing,
achieving your values,
having taken responsibility,
set yourself goals and leading a life where you're achieving those goals over
time.
And I think that's what ethics is about.
I think that's what gives meaning to life and really be part of that is taking
responsibility for yourself.
I would,
I a little bit bristled at the idea of saying that responsibility is more
important than rights or the reverse.
I think there are there issues that come up at a different tier.
So I think taking responsibility for yourself as a matter of ethics,
it's a matter of how you live your own life.
It's a matter of how you lead a life worth living and be happy and have meaning.
I think those go together.
Um,
but then right are the conditions that we need when we organize as a society to
make everybody able to do that and not to be in fight impinging on each other.
And if we don't all value our own lives.
And happiness.
If we're not all taking responsibility or at least many of us aren't,
we're not going to have a society that cares about rights and they're going to
go away.
And um,
so in that sense,
I agree.
We need to have this shift to talking about ethics and uh,
what we want to make of our lives.
Each of us you're on.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
when we talk about the individual,
I think one of the points that each that's important to make is the individual
support.
And partially because that's all we got,
right?
In a sense,
all you got is individuals.
We can talk about society,
but society is just a collection of individuals that starting point,
both in ethics and in politics has to be the unit of value.
The unit that actually exist in metaphysical value unit that exists,
not the abstraction that we call the state or society.
What's important is the ability of the individual to live a good life,
to take responsibility for his own life,
his own happiness for his own success,
for his own flourishing.
So the individual is,
is,
is everything.
When he comes in my view in morality and,
and,
and uh,
and then as an extension in politics.
And I think rights are the concept that recognize that is,
it's the bridge,
right?
So the bridge between a morality that says your moral responsibility is to make
the most of your life.
And then what kind of political systems should we live in?
Cat should we live in to make that possible?
And writes,
recognizes that the enemy of the good life,
the enemy of flourishing,
the enemy of success at living is corrosion.
Enforce.
It's,
it's the group,
the states,
the,
the community,
other people,
other individuals coursing pro,
uh,
being authoritarian over you,
telling you how you must live in how you must act and rights.
Recognize that as individuals we have freedom.
We must be free to use our own judgments to live our own lives as we see fit.
And that's the great revolution of,
of the enlightenment is,
is the recognition of the sanctity of the individual and creating a political
system that allows the individual to flourish and to thrive by protecting him
from coercion,
by protecting him for force.
And relegating the state to that duty.
The responsibility of the state is to protect rights to protect you from force.
So it seems to me that the battle between the individual and the collective is a
battle that has been fought for virtually every society for all time.
However,
there does seem to me at least,
and maybe it's just because I'm alive right now and doing what I do,
that there's something unique about the battle at the moment that the individual
has been slammed so relentlessly and that we have ideas out there now that for,
for young people that they think that socialism is cool.
I mean that seems to be coming back,
right?
I mean these are,
these are ideas that I think are,
are really crazy,
but I'm happy to indulge in,
in the discussion about them.
Do you think there's anything unique about the,
the battle between the individual and the collective right now?
Or is this just a repeating of what's gone on decades?
I think,
I mean there's always something unique about each historical moment,
but I think this is me.
This is being a continuous argument for the last hundred and 30 years.
Like as a technical philosophical argument.
And,
and of course it has roots that go back much farther than that.
I don't see,
I mean it is collectivism,
individualism,
I think the fundamental polarizing force that's,
that's it's,
that's at work at the moment.
And the issue with the collectivist types is whether or not they're
collectivists because they care about the dispossessed,
which is their fundamental claim or whether they're collectivists because they
don't want to bear any of the responsibility that would go along with being a
responsible individual.
And,
you know,
I'm always skeptical of the,
of the saint like moral claims that are put forth by people who are pushing and
given ideology.
And now I'm,
I'm skeptical about that on my part too.
And the people who criticize my perspective say,
look,
Dr. Peterson,
you're not,
or maybe they call me something a lot less flattering,
you know,
they say you're not,
you're not,
um,
you're,
you're underestimating the degree to which systemic barriers make it impossible
for people to move forward properly in the world.
There's,
there's barriers to the progress that people can make,
even if they barely individual responsibility.
And those barriers are distributed on equally.
And of course there's some truth in that because every system
tends towards rigidity and tyranny and no system does a perfect job of selecting
among its people for pure competence.
But there's a difference between saying that a system is somewhat corrupt,
which is certainly the case with western systems.
And the system is an absolutely corrupt,
tyrannical patriarchy with no hope of redemption whatsoever.
It needs to be burned to the ground and reformulated.
Those are really different.
And you know,
it's,
it's also possible to be sensible and say,
well look,
I mean obviously the manner in which people are selected for success in our
society is imperfect.
Um,
but also to note,
well imperfect compared to what exactly like to your hypothetical Utopian
perfection,
which you would self-generate if you were given ultimate power.
Cause that's really the comparison or to our societies in the past because we're
doing a lot better now than we were or compared to every other society that's
ever existed since the dawn of time,
by which standard we are doing so insanely well that it's actually almost
unbelievable.
And,
and this is another thing that I've been trying to promote.
I mean there's been at least a dozen books written in the last six or seven
years by fairly serious scholars and I would say distributed across the,
the,
the political spectrum pointing out that like ever since the year 2000 things
are getting better so fast that it's actually a miracle.
You know,
and I can give you some quick facts.
So the rate of absolute poverty in the world fell by by 50% between the year
2000 and 2012 so that's a staggering achievement.
It was three years faster than the most optimistic projections of the UN.
So we actually beat in optimistic UN projection.
So there are more,
well that's,
it's absolutely beyond belief.
There are more forests in,
in,
in the northern hemisphere now than there were a hundred years ago.
Um,
the child mortality rate in Africa is now lower than it was in Europe in 1950,
which is just beyond belief.
The fastest growing economies in the world or in sub Saharan Africa,
um,
about 300,000 people.
I can't remember if it's a day or a week,
but it doesn't matter.
Although it would be better if it was a day,
obviously are being plugged into the electrical grid.
So increasingly people have universal access to fresh water.
There's almost no country in the world.
Now we're starvation is a problem that isn't just a political problem,
which is to say we have enough food for everyone and not only do we have enough
food,
we have the distribution systems that are actually getting that food to
everyone.
It's absolutely beyond belief.
And what's,
what's quite remarkable about that is it's quite obvious that individually,
like that free market system is predicated on the idea of the sovereignty of the
individual are the reason that that's happening.
So
[inaudible].
So the question
can is,
what the hell are the collectivists up to?
You know,
why are they [inaudible] like what's the problem here?
And the problem,
the problem seems to be a certain amount of ignorance,
a certain amount of willful blindness and a certain amount of discomfort with
the fact that a fair bit of that wealth has been purchased at the price of a
continuing inequality.
We don't know how to generate wealth without also generating inequality,
and I actually don't think that you can generate wealth without generating
inequality and that's well,
that's something that's worth it,
right?
Let's say discussion.
I think
a little something to say about inequality.
We wrote a book about that.
Yeah.
I mean,
I like to say it in brief,
right?
Inequality is a feature of freedom,
not a buck.
It just
comes with freedom.
You have totally right.
You
cannot create wealth without any quality,
and there's nothing wrong with any quality.
There's nothing bad about inequality.
There's nothing a model the offensive about inequality and in particular,
given that what happens is that everybody's getting richer.
Everybody gets Richard,
they just get Richard at different patient who reason they get Richard at
different pace is because they're producing different quantities of value.
The people who actually get very rich in a free market.
Now we don't have a pure free market and all kinds of problems with the system
we have.
But in a free market,
you only gain those values that you produce.
A Jeff Bezos is the re is the richest person in the world because how many of
you shop on Amazon?
Everybody,
right?
So there's a reason he's produced values that have affected almost every human
being on the planet.
And that's that.
That is why he,
you know,
he's so wealthy.
So the whole debate is,
is to try to drive people towards envy.
The whole inequality debate is to try to undercut the,
uh,
the idea of freedom because what they're really after is not reducing
inequality.
What they're really after is eliminating freedom.
Uh,
it's the same people who used to advocate for an ideology of communism or
socialism.
Now that's been discredited.
So they have to call it something else.
Joe Stiglitz that Nobel Prize winner in economics,
it's not going to come out for communism,
but in a sense he used that as the mall ideal.
You can't get there.
It's rough.
There's a little too violence.
Too much blood for his tastes.
He's an economist after.
All right,
so so inequalities on nice disguise or we want to reduce inequality might
debates with people.
We talk about.
Any quality to say by how much,
well,
we'll know when we get there.
Who will know,
who gets to decide,
how are we going to vote,
how much are we going to take and why?
Why just monitoring inequality.
I mean,
Dave's a good looking guy.
It's not fan.
Can I?
Can I have some of that?
And it's a lot.
It's a lot of hairspray,
man.
I mean how do,
how do we,
how do we do that?
How do you,
we,
you know,
there'd be an experiments and trying to equalize in the book,
we give the example of course,
if the tragedy of,
of,
of the horrific tragedy of Cambodia and the camera moves with the attempt is to
equalize not just,
not just on,
on monitoring issues,
but on smarts or the only way to do that is to kill the educated and smart on,
on every other fact on who's a good farmer and who's a good,
good father Jeff for food,
they killed them all.
40% of the population.
It's so I,
yeah,
so the whole,
I mean I get,
I get really upset with people even make an issue of inequality because it
shouldn't be an issue with equality.
And I think it's changed I think in America 50 years ago and I'm not trying to
be nostalgic because I know the dangers in that.
It just,
it,
there wasn't this idea nobody cared,
right.
Because there was this feeling that you earned it,
you worked hard,
you made it.
There was also a feeling that,
see,
I'm not so sure people care as much about inequality as they care about
inequalities of hypothetical trajectory.
So meaning that it isn't so bad if you're rich and I'm poor,
if I believe that if I put my best foot forward,
I might also,
my life will improve across time.
Or even if mine doesn't mind,
children's life will because I think people are more interested.
I think people vote their dreams rather than the reality and the dream has to be
intact.
And I do have a couple of just one thing.
I think that's true,
but it's also true that people,
people resent wealth when they think it's unearned.
Yeah.
And I think the more,
the more we move towards a centrally planned economy,
the more we have cronyism,
the more the real problems in the kind of the mixed economy that we have.
We don't have pure capitalism.
Then the
more they're suspicious of the people at the top because indeed they see the
people at the top schmoozing with the politicians,
and that's what scares them.
So I think America has shifted partially because they're not sure that people
have earned it and partially because they've been bombarded with this message,
you should envied them.
It's,
it's immoral inequality.
So,
so I think it's a combination.
The combination of the dream,
the justice of it is that just for somebody to have to have that wealth because
they've earned it.
And this issue of,
of Dave just there's been a shift in the morality in the mall perception.
I think we have a,
we have a structural problem that's going to emerge to that.
And this is where I would take some issue I suppose with the,
with the idea that there's nothing intrinsically bad about inequality.
I mean because it presumes something approximating a level playing field and I'm
not thinking so much about systemic barriers.
Well,
let,
let me just make the argument very briefly as you're,
tell me what you think because one of the things that I spend a lot of time
looking at what predicts success in,
in,
in western and functional Western hierarchies and the two intrinsic
psychological factors that predict success.
Our intelligence as you assess it with Iq tests,
which is the best way to assess intelligence by,
by,
by an overwhelming margin and trait conscientiousness,
which is industriousness and orderliness,
sometimes known as grit.
Um,
and those are quite good predictors of longterm success.
They account for about 40% of the variability across time,
which leaves a lot of other factors still at play.
But there's something quite terrifying about the intelligence and of that
equation because Iq is,
is normally distributed in the population and there's incredible differences
between people who are at the top of the,
I could distribution and people who are at the bottom like it,
you can't believe how variable people are in their intelligence.
It's quite staggering.
Well,
I can give you an example.
So it's actually illegal in the United States to induct someone into the armed
forces if they have an Iq of less than 83.
And the reason for that is that they aren't forced as determined after a hundred
and some years of,
of extraordinarily rigorous testing,
um,
motivated by the hope that everyone would be fodder for the armed forces.
Cause that's their hope,
right?
Because they have a chronic manpower shortage,
peacetime and wartime.
So they want people in the armed forces,
they're not going to exclude them unless they have to.
And the consequence of the analysis was that if you have an Iq of 83 or less,
there isn't anything you can be trained to do in the armed forces that isn't
positively counterproductive.
It's like,
yes,
yes.
And this is a way bigger fact than you think because that's about 10% of the
population.
And so,
so we have a problem and,
and I would say it's a problem that is,
is going to manifest itself in something that approximates a and inequality that
looks unfair because there are the cognitively dispossessed are going to have a
very rough time competing.
They already do.
I mean there's,
there's absolutely no doubt about that.
And so it,
it see,
the problem with,
with producing hierarchies and even allowing people to climb up the hierarchies
responsibly is that the hierarchy is still produced dispossession at the bottom.
And we need to figure out how to deal with that.
Even if the only consequence of that disposition is the generation of envy.
Because envy can bring down the state and you might tell people while you have a
moral responsibility not to be envious and fair enough.
Perhaps you do,
but it isn't clear that that's going to be sufficient solution to solve the
problem.
And we also have the cognitive problem that no one will talk about and that we
should talk about because it's a real,
it's real.
So,
so it sounds like we're talking about the same thing,
whether we're talking about it from a cognitive perspective or a financial
perspective that in terms of inequality,
it's not really the,
all the people sort of at the bottom,
but it's the,
it's the bottom of the bottom that can't help themselves.
That seems like maybe,
what do you do about that one point that rent made about this?
And I think making this point is part of the solution to,
um,
to people being envious,
uh,
letting people internalize this point
is that other people's goodness,
other people's accomplishments,
other people's intelligence,
other people's wealth if they've earned it.
And a society that enables the most productive,
smartest people to achieve what they can achieve is good for everyone and
especially good for the people at the bottom of whatever hierarchy we might be
talking about of whatever level of ability,
whatever level of money.
And we can see that in giving a little bit more freedom,
a little bit more capitalism in countries like China and India has helped while
everyone there,
but disproportionately the Boris people who were starving to death,
who had incredible infant mortality rates than what you were talking about this
before.
And we've seen them go down.
Uh,
so I think envy it part of the cause of envy is a
wrong moral views that people have moral views that hold that the purpose of
someone's life isn't to achieve things in their own life,
isn't to reach their own happiness,
isn't to form a company like Microsoft and get a computer on every desk in the
world running Microsoft software.
Uh,
if someone does that,
we think he's selfish,
we think it's bad,
or at least it's neutral and we envy him and resent him if we're brought up to
think that way.
Whereas if we're brought up to appreciate the people who created this tremendous
prosperity that those of you were talking about,
and to see that as morally good and there's right and as benefiting all of us
but benefiting us,
not because they did it for us,
but because I'm taking responsibility for your life,
having gold,
having something you want out of life,
leading a life of your own on a grand scale,
uh,
for your own sake is what benefits not only you,
but makes you evaluate everybody else.
If we had a society that understood that,
I think that combat the MV and one of the things that rand wrote,
she had a really interesting article called the age of envy that talked about,
um,
and also another article called the untitled letter,
which was a comment on role and she was very concerned about this kind of
egalitarianism and just kind of growing Neil Ism and the envy and the culture.
Um,
it was,
she thought a bit of an American if even the kind of thing.
It is more characteristic of Europe in the 14th.
And this wasn't an American way of thinking,
but it was catching on here.
And I think she was prophetic in that.
I think we're seeing a lot of that today.
So let's shift a little bit because I know we can talk about inequality and the
individual and all that.
We can,
we can do that all night long.
But the,
the title of this talk is philosophy and the human soul.
So we only talked for literally about 20 seconds.
The four of us before,
you know,
we didn't plan anything about what we were going to do here.
Um,
so I thought that the best way to start that would be how would you even define
the soul you're on?
I'll start with you.
Really.
Yeah.
You got a psychologist or a philosopher and a finance guy and [inaudible] my
job,
man.
We are,
and you know the movie
Brisbin finance guys have no,
I mean I was actually going to start
with Jordan,
but you look down for a second.
Yeah,
yeah.
The cue that I should go,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't have,
I don't have a succinct,
clear definition of it,
but it has to do with,
with consciousness and values.
It has to do with,
with,
with our conscious experiences as some of our conscious experiences I'll,
I'll,
I'll be in and the values that we have as individuals or things that are most
important to us and that I think experience is what I would refer to as our soul
or spirit.
You know,
I think these are somewhat interchangeable.
When I talk about spiritual experiences,
it's just,
it's an experience of consciousness.
It's a,
you know,
if you listened to a piece of music and,
and the combination of emotion values and,
and your conscious listening and absorbing,
that to me is what spirit soul would mean.
That's great.
Yeah.
I would say,
um,
speaking of the philosopher in the first death of ran scholar here,
she had the,
the freeze that man at the being of self need salt.
So the idea here is your soul is your consciousness,
um,
at the faculty.
Your ability to know when to think,
uh,
but also you have to build who you are,
build your character,
build your personality,
build your values,
come to value things,
set your life around them.
By doing that over time and pursuing them,
you develop a character.
You develop into a certain type of person.
You develop into a distinct individual.
Knew that a beautiful line in the,
in the fountain head,
um,
which this is the theme of this conference.
Uh,
someone talks about how most people long for immortality,
but when you meet them the next time,
they weren't the same as they were the last.
They're beautiful.
They're constantly changing what they're after.
It's constantly changing,
but the hero of the novel,
Dear Friend says,
you could imagine him existing distinct forever.
He's achieved in mortality in his day to day life because there's a constancy to
them and that kind of constancy that having a soul,
having an eye,
being a particular person,
it's an achievement.
It's the achievement of having formed values,
having formed something you want out of your life and then having built for
yourself through living this way.
A character that's adapted to that,
a character that focused on that.
You know,
this reminds me of groundhog day in a way because in the Q and A's that we've
been doing for the last couple of months,
a couple of times it's come up.
What's your favorite comedy?
And you've mentioned groundhog day where he has to go.
Maria has to consistently come back and do it better and do it
better and do it better and do it better.
Now I've set you up,
what is your definition of the soul?
Well,
I was thinking that the words that hand that writes and then moves on came into
my mind and then I was thinking,
well,
this is the way I conceptualize how consciousness works.
And so maybe this is in some sense the locale of the soul.
So I don't believe that we're driven deterministically like obviously we are to
some degree,
but I don't think that that's the right way of conceptualizing how con human
consciousness works.
I think it's putting the cart before the horse in some sense.
So the way it looks to me is that what we have arrayed in front of us is a
landscape of possibility.
And I think that that's phenomenologically uh,
accurate.
You know,
when you wake up in the morning,
especially when you wake up at three in the morning and you're,
you're concerned about how your life is going,
you see an array of possible futures manifest themselves in front of you.
And you know,
there are more possible futures.
Of course,
then you can imagine,
but there's plenty that make themselves manifest.
I could do this,
I could do that.
This could happen.
What about this?
Maybe I should do this.
And it's like there's a branching landscape in front of you and some of the
places that you're headed to are more likely than others.
And some of them take a lot more effort to attain than others,
but it's a distribution of possible landscapes.
And that's actually your reality.
It's not like you're driven deterministically by the present.
You see a branching landscape of possibility in front of you.
And I think of that as potential.
And we all know about potential because we upgrade ourselves and each other for
not living up to our potential,
which is a very interesting thing that we do because potential isn't something
concrete.
And in fact,
it's the opposite of concrete.
And yet we act as if it's the most real thing.
You should live up to your potential,
you know,
and,
and your conscience will bother you if you don't live up to your potential.
So you have a potential and there's a potential that manifests itself.
And then what you seem to do is that you make choices between those alternative
realities.
And you do that in part imposing a value structure on them and,
and,
and deriving a pathway as a consequence of that.
But you decide which of those potentials are going to manifest themselves in
actuality.
And so you are the hand that writes that and then move so on.
And this is a very deep idea.
I mean,
I,
I've traced it back to two.
I think our most profound religious intuitions,
um,
the idea that,
that it was the word of God,
for example,
that gave rise to habitable order out of chaos at the beginning of time,
I think is a reflection of the same idea.
I think the soul is the thing that mediates between potential and actuality.
And I mean that literally and metaphorically at the same time,
that's what you're doing is you're confronting potential,
which is that which could be,
and you're deciding which of that is going to be.
And the thing that's doing that is the soul and that's its divine task.
And I think the fact that you do that is actually why it's necessary for
societies to grant you the idea of intrinsic,
right?
Sorry.
Nope.
That's why it's necessary for functional society or societies to be predicated
on the idea that you have intrinsic value is because you actually are the locale
where potential transforms itself into actuality.
And so we determine the actual,
the action of our soul determines the actuality of the world.
I think that's genuinely the case.
So this is really interesting to me
because I'm watching you guys and I can see a lot of agreement,
but obviously Jordan made at least two references to God and religion there.
Now obviously this is where an objectivist and Jordan would have a point of
disagreement.
This is why you're doing these public events with Sam Harris.
And one of the things that I been thinking about it as we've been on tour is at
the end of the day,
if we all ultimately agree and if everyone in this room,
if we could ultimately agree on a morality and,
and the definition of the soul,
that all made sense.
And Jordan's perhaps was had a more religious connotation and yours didn't.
And we all could live functioning good lives within that.
Then does it really matter beyond the,
the interest in the intellectual discussion because there was a lot of
agreement.
I could see it in your body language and both of you guys.
Greg,
I'll start with you.
Well,
let me start with some of the things I agree with a lot and including some of
the use of religious language with it.
There's a good reason for even for those of us who aren't religious or don't
think of herself that,
and I think I think of myself with an atheist family,
but um,
though I know you,
uh,
interpret that word differently.
Um,
but
he'll tell you [inaudible] occupant.
But um,
so first of all,
I think what we see in what you're describing about the many manifold potentials
in the soul actualizes it is a conviction,
which I very much agree with and I think we can know is true.
And I think I agree.
We presuppose and all of our thinking and all of our judging of people,
which is that we have free will if there's not a future that's written in.
We're just on a path traveling down at.
But rather in every moment we're able to make choices and our choices change the
future.
And that is a really profound fact.
Uh,
it's a profound factor about our consciousness.
It's connected to everything else that's a value about us.
And I agree.
If that wasn't true of us,
we'd be a very different kind of creature.
We wouldn't interact with each others in the same way.
We wouldn't need the same kind of political structure.
And it's,
it's such a profound fact about us that we don't really have language for it,
are very good language for it.
Um,
religion has been the form in which people have thought about the most profound
facts,
about their most profound experiences,
about their understandings of them from well,
from,
as long as there's been people are,
as long as there's been any way for a very,
very long time.
Um,
and the Z as we've lost religion,
um,
we haven't found ways or haven't always found ways to conceptualize
independently of religion.
Um,
those kinds of profound values,
the profound role of freedom and human life,
the,
um,
what our highest potential is.
And so if you're going to talk about those things,
it's very hard to do it without really reaching for at least religious metaphor.
That's a really crucial issue.
You know,
I think,
I think it's a fundamentally crucial issue.
But I want to say though,
just to finish the disagree in part what's true,
what's true matters,
right?
And something can be a beautiful metaphor,
but if understood,
literally is false.
And one of the things I think we need to do to lead our lives well to achieve
these kinds of values is to really value our minds and value or reason and value
getting at the truth.
So if it turns out that something's false,
then believing that it's true is not going to make our lives better.
And,
um,
so I don't think it could turn out that we're going to have a very deep
disagreement about what's true about the basic facts of reality and yet we're
all going to be hunky Dory on everything else.
I think those disagreements will make a difference,
but we have to acknowledge the role of consciousness and freedom in life.
And I think there is an agreement between us on that.
Well,
what I've observed is for example,
in my clinical practice when,
when I'm talking about life and death,
moral issues and these are in situations where extreme things are happening in
families and in individuals lives,
talking about events that might've produced post traumatic stress disorder or
that set people up for murder it at times or suicide like um,
or terrible suffering,
some of which is induced voluntarily.
The probability that I can have a discussion with my clients about that at a
level that will be salutary without using met religious slash metaphorical
language is zero.
I can't,
if I can't,
if the discussion can take place in the domain of good versus evil,
something like that.
And this is especially true,
I would say for post traumatic stress disorder,
you just don't get anywhere with it.
And W I've been thinking about the,
the,
the narrative issue a lot constantly.
And I think that,
I know we need to use this,
this is one of the weaknesses of the rationalist argument I think is that we
have to use heuristics to operate in the world.
So heuristics are simply are simplifying maneuvers and we,
there's no option.
You have to use heuristics.
And the reason for that is because there is a lot more world than there is a
view.
And so you take this incredibly complex reality and you simplify it and now the
simplifications have to have merit.
And what makes them have merit is,
is grounds for,
is a topic for a very long,
lengthy discussion.
But to produce those simplifications you have to use here eristics you have to
use cognitive shortcuts.
And it looks to me like narrative is a heuristic.
And that the reason that we need to tell stories and that we probably need to
have our ethic grounded in stories is because you can make a list of rules that
will tell you how to live.
Rules don't suffice,
but you can tell stories that are,
that lay out broad principles and those are heuristic principles now.
But the thing is is that the most fundamental stories seem to have a religious
core.
Now,
I'm not exactly sure why that is,
although I think it probably has to do with something I referred to earlier,
which is the idea that you know you are as a soul,
you're the thing that transforms potential into actuality.
That seems to be the grounding concept in some sense.
So that's the grounding concept.
There's something divine about that.
Out of that arise as a sequence of stories that are shaped across perhaps
evolutionary history and inside that are more articulated ethic exists.
And I don't see a way out of that because you cannot make an exhaustive list of
rules that enable ethical movement forward.
And you need to do that.
If you had a purely rational view of the way that human cognition functions.
It's something like that.
So let's,
let's pause right there.
Can either one of you figure out a way out of that?
I mean that,
right?
That would be the answer that in,
and this would want to want to have right here we are.
We got a whole budget right?
Ready yet?
I don't think you could have a list of rules.
If the rules,
your meetings look like an algorithm that you guys,
your life.
I think that's just not something we can do.
That's not the way the human mind works in the world is complicated and you're
not gonna get a bunch of,
if then statements that take you,
uh,
take you to do them.
You can't even do that for a lot of physical systems do with when.
Right?
Um,
but I think we can understand them rationally.
I know this might be similar to what we were talking about in the green room
about Sam through of reason and yours in,
we might got to figure out where they all a lie,
but I don't think reason is just about coming up with algorithms.
I think we come up with concepts,
concepts enable us to assimilate vast quantities of similar things to one
another and learn from future about future instances from past ones.
We can get quite subtle,
um,
principals,
but I think moral principles are not things that take the form of simple rules.
Don't lie there.
Um,
to take Rand's version of the virtue of honesty,
which isn't,
don't lie,
it's um,
it's your recognition of the fact that what's unreal is unreal and it can't be a
value.
So faking things won't work.
It won't make them real.
Somehow the thing you fake,
it's going to come back to haunt you.
That's not a simple rule of what to do in each situation.
It's a kind of broad fact that you can use to steer your life by and in order to
use it this year,
life by into fully understand it.
You need to think about how it plays out in a lot of different contexts,
right?
You need to think about what it really means in practice and art of stories,
but you know,
literature.
But also other forms of art I think are an indispensable means to doing this
both with ethical truths like this and also with other metaphysical trues views
about what kind of wherein,
sure.
I guess part of the part of the discussion and as it progresses we'll,
I don't necessarily mean this discussion in particular,
but you know,
obviously I'm not an enemy of reason by any stretch of the imagination,
but I do see that it's hard for people who promote reason as the fundamental
mechanism to distinguish between reason and the generation of algorithms.
Like,
and you can say,
well my concept of reason extends beyond the generation of Algorithms and fine,
but then my question would be,
well,
exactly what are the mechanisms by which reason functions when what it's doing
isn't generating algorithms because algorithms aren't enough.
And we know that,
right?
Which is why we don't have expert diagnostic systems,
for example.
So then the,
the reason starts to look something like metaphor.
It starts to look something like narrative and then I start thinking,
yeah,
but that's not exactly the enlightenment concept of reasons.
So we're starting to move into,
uh,
a different domain.
And so more than just algorithm than metaphor and narrative.
I think first of all,
one thing reason can do,
we've come up with metaphors and narrative,
but there's more than just those three things.
They'd also think there's the formation of abstract principles.
I don't think what Newton did in writing the print Skipio was coming up with
algorithms.
There are algorithms in it,
but or things you can algorithmize about how to prove certain things.
But the act of forming the concept inertia,
that's not exactly,
you know,
that's something else.
And I think it's an inertia might be an algorithm,
but the act of coming up with it sampling.
Yes.
And I think there's a whole,
an underexplored area of philosophy and they'd be cognitive psychology thinking
about what are the,
that have reason?
How did the reason function,
how is it that we can go from the kind of information we have in to a more and
more sophisticated understanding of the world?
And um,
I mean I've written some on this.
Other people have,
uh,
I don't know.
I don't know how much I should try to explain here,
but I can plug a,
I have a chapter called conceptualization and justification in a book called
concepts and their role in knowledge.
That gives my sense of what reason does here
see.
Cause here,
the other thing that's come up among the cognitive scientists in particular and
also the robotics types is,
is,
is as,
as people,
and this is Rodney Brooks in particular,
who invented the room by,
by the way,
but who's,
who's an absolute,
well,
it's a major accomplishment because the room that doesn't have a brain,
but it operates intelligently,
like it's a major accomplishment,
that thing.
And it took Brooks Brooks actually reconstructed how artificial intelligence,
robotics engineers who are conceptualizing intelligence.
And he thought of it as something much more embodied rather than conceptual.
So it was the room was actually the consequence of very,
very high level thinking about the relationship between reason and action in the
world.
Like one of the things that caught in the more sophisticated cognitive
psychologists have been wrestling with is the fact that a lot of what we thought
of as abstract reason is actually something that's more dependent on embodiment
than we'd ever,
ever possibly conceived.
Right.
And so the idea of disembark need reason,
which is also I would say an enlightenment concept seems to be lacking.
It's lacking in functionality.
You have to be embodied.
And the thing to me is that an embodied reason looks to me a lot more like the
hero of a story than it looks like disembodied reasons,
I think.
I think that's a better metaphor.
And so partly why I like the idea of the logos,
for example rather than the idea of reason is because,
and this is partly reflected in its in its conceptual Christian origins because
the logo's in Christianity is something that's actually embodied,
right?
It's the word made flesh.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a link between the rational logos logic and the thing that's embodied
and it's the interaction between those two that producers I think produces that
phenomenon that you described as what drove,
um,
Newton for example,
when he was producing his algorithms.
That's not an algorithm.
It's something else,
but it's not this certainly not disembodied reasons,
but even that
before of the word made flesh,
right.
It sounds as though something that could have been different bodied was
disembodied once and now it got embodied.
And so it still sounds to me a little bit too much like this,
a disembodied conception of you want to call it reason or mind.
Um,
whereas I think we want to conception of what reason is and what it does that
involves the fact from the start that it's a fee of a feature of certain living
organisms.
Uh,
these organisms have perceptual systems,
those are bodily at anything is,
and it's,
um,
a faculty of integrating the data that's coming in through those,
uh,
those organs helping us direct ourselves through the world.
Uh,
and then on a grander and grander scale.
So I think in the enlightenment,
what we're getting is a lot of reflection for the first time or for one of the
first time they're renewed reflection on reason,
what it is,
how it works.
And there are several different views,
right?
Some more materialistic views like in the whole block and so forth and then sees
more,
um,
the Cartesian type views.
And I think most of the views that came out of that are wrong.
And I think it's,
it's sad because it's a period when people were really valuing the mind or their
predominant,
trying to understand it wrong.
Well,
you know,
because they go on to somewhere else.
But it certainly does seem the case that,
and this is again,
I think the problem with the idea of reason per say is that it's not a
sufficiently differentiated idea to account for how it is that we actually
operate in the world.
And so,
and,
and the AI types and the psychologists are really trying to sort that out.
But see,
one of the things that happen to me when I was arguing with Sam Harris about
this,
cause Sam believes that you can drive values from facts and more or less in an
unmediated way.
Although he,
he,
he has some differences of opinion with himself about how unmediated that is.
It's like,
it's,
well,
I mean it's very difficult to be entirely coherent when you think something
through something that's complicated,
there's,
there's likely to be in consistencies in your argument because it's so
complicated.
But it looks to me like it's actually formerly impossible to derive value from
facts in an unmediated sense.
You need something to mediate between the facts and the values.
And,
and then I would also say it looks like it's impossible for you to derive that
structure merely over the course of your life.
You don't,
you don't have enough time.
You're not smart enough and you don't have enough time.
And so you have an embodied biological platform or you are that embodied
biological platform.
And it's actually the consequence of let's say,
at least in part evolutionary presser pressures operating over about a 3.5
billion year period.
And so it's possible that you can derive facts from values,
but it takes you three and a half billion years to do it properly.
And,
and,
and what you have that allows you to do that in your life,
to look at a set of facts and to decide how to proceed is the intermediation,
the unconscious intermediation of that unbelievably deep structure.
And when I've said to Sam something that really annoys him,
I said,
well,
you think you're an atheist but you're actually not.
What I'm actually saying is your conscious apprehension of yourself is a very
thin layer that's laid on top of what you are because you don't know who you
are.
And most of what you do is unconscious.
And that's actually a nun.
There isn't a serious cognitive psychologists in the world who doesn't think
that most of what you do is unconscious by the way.
And I would say that unconscious has a structure and that's a narrative
structure.
And that narrative structure is deep.
And so that even if you describe yourself as atheistic,
because in the,
in the explicit content of your thinking,
you see no room for the grounding of your conceptions in divinity.
I would say,
well that isn't how your unconscious is structured all
and now.
Yeah,
and you,
you might object,
but then then the objection,
well,
how are you structured?
Structured since it's 99% of you,
I think I've got a guy over there with a slight objection.
He almost jumped out of this chair.
How was your unconscious structures,
which by the way,
I think this is particularly interesting because I think you have a lot of
agreements with Jordan on plenty of stuff.
And I think you have a lot of agreements with Sam on plenty of stuff.
But this is where this argument has gotten down to.
It's a really,
really rich place,
I think.
Well,
I mean it's,
this is,
this is the,
the,
the big issue,
right?
So I have agreements with Sam on stuff for different,
but we have different reasons for having that agreement.
Uh,
and so for example,
I agree with him.
I,
it was odd,
but his conception of his art is very different than our conception of his art.
And he has no freewill in that concept one.
So that blows my mind how you can even talk about in his odd values without
having free will.
And,
and,
and he talks about choices without freewill,
which,
uh,
which is challenging.
Um,
um,
well we [inaudible] we'll do that on and then we might come.
Well,
we might come to some agreement about,
about,
I don't know who writes or something,
uh,
with children,
although I think even now,
even our conception of rights is going to be a little different because I don't
see how you can get through rights without understanding of what was the reason
and,
and how recent functions and what the enemy of reason ultimately is,
which is,
which is what I mentioned earlier,
which is force.
Um,
so,
so I think to go back to your original question way back,
um,
I think there's no way for us to have different foundations and not come up with
different conclusions.
We're going to have to come up with different conclusions.
Now we might agree on certain issues in politics was,
for example,
I think we're going to disagree quite profoundly on ethics,
right?
I think,
you know,
just watching someone Jordan things and on sacrifice and so on,
on the role of Jesus,
Oh,
oh,
off you have Jesus is going to be very,
very profoundly different.
And that affects human behavior.
That affects individual human behavior.
So they're going to be,
you can't start with different premises and develop them and come up with
exactly the same way and say,
okay,
we agree on this stuff,
but no,
these,
these things have profound consequences.
The disagreements have a profound,
profound consequences.
Now,
when I think of my subconscious,
I don't think of it as this as this.
And again,
I'm not,
not a philosopher,
not a psychologist.
So this is the way a layman in these terms,
we think,
I think of my side of my psychologist,
my subconscious not as a 99% darkness out down there,
right?
I think of it as,
as,
as something that accumulated information,
conclusions,
uh,
values,
decisions that I've made over since childhood since before he was completely
conscious of them,
that they,
I have access to some of them,
uh,
you know,
hopefully cognitive psychology and how psychology can help me get access to more
of them,
but they're accessible to,
they're not some mystery there,
accessible to me.
And that when I am making a decision in life,
uh,
I try to make it based on what I know,
not based on what I don't know that's back there.
Right?
So I try to accumulate facts.
This is the finance guy in me right over the reality guy in me.
I tried to accumulate facts and,
and,
and integrate them and try to distinguish between what f which facts are
legitimate and which facts are illegitimate and try to integrate them and try to
make a decision based on logic,
based on,
based on reality.
And you know,
sometimes my emotion will say,
and this is my subconscious,
maybe speaking,
uh,
don't do that.
Or that's a bad thing.
But so what?
Right.
If,
if,
if reality.
And the fact,
uh,
with me,
then I'll ignore that subconscious.
So I don't see us as,
we've got some choice over here,
but we're really driven by the subconscious.
The subconscious is there for me to explore and I become a better person as I
know my subconscious better.
I had to stand where my emotions are coming from and I understand that better.
But at the end of the day,
when I make a choice out there,
it's based on reality and fact and C,
c,
C and I,
and I see reality of facts.
I don't see anything coming between me and this and this plastic bottle that
again,
uh,
my simplistic view right there.
Here's the,
here's the plastic bottle.
I can see it.
It's a plastic bottle.
And,
and uh,
it's not something else.
Not as,
there's a lot that goes into what is plastic,
what is bottle,
what does that,
but that's what it is.
I can describe it.
I can actually,
if I had the scientific knowledge,
get down into the molecular structure and it's real.
It's actually here.
It's not created by,
by consciousness or interpreted by my consciousness.
It really is what it is.
So I,
I think what evolution has done has given us those tools.
[inaudible] question.
Sure.
Why is this,
why is this stump in a beanbag?
Both a chair?
Well,
because you're talking about is a stump and a bean bag.
Both a che.
Because if you have a proper definition of a chair,
then a stomping and big bag both fit the definition.
Well,
I haven't thought about it,
but you know something to sit in.
That's it.
Yeah.
So it's something to sit on.
Right.
That isn't inherent to the object.
Sure,
no to.
But my,
my definition definitions are not habits in the object.
The,
the,
the objective of the created by,
by,
you know,
my consciousness and that object,
that object is an object,
right?
It is,
it is.
It's both of them are chairs in both of them have a particular nature that is,
I can describe both.
I can both say the stump and the bean bag or the same there were chair,
but I can also say the different,
the stump is made of wood and it has this one.
Let's say the drawback is that the problem with the idea that the object
presents itself is that two things are the same and different in the near
infinite number of ways and that that's also a technical problem.
So I can give you an example.
So imagine that you're going to classify a set of six books.
You're going to figure out how to arrange them in your shelf.
You think,
well that's an easy thing to do.
That's a conceptual problem by the way,
it's actually not an easy thing to do because there is an indefinite number of
ways that you can classify a finite number of objects.
So you could classify the books by color,
by age,
by thickness,
by weight,
by number of ease,
by number of A's,
by number of ease on the first page,
by number of words,
by number of phrases.
[inaudible] question is,
why am I classifying them?
So that is the question.
There's no intrinsic value to classifying books.
The question is why do I want to classify them and the answer to the why I want
to classify them.
We'll then determine how I clashed.
Absolutely.
That's exactly it,
but that's the rub.
The rub is you see that's the rub.
Your classification system is dependent on why you apply it and that's exactly
the argument I've been using with Harris,
which means the set of facts that reveal themselves to you in the world are
dependent on your values.
Cause sounds argument is that the values are derived from the fact.
It's like,
no,
wait a minute.
There's an infinite number of facts and they present themselves in accordance
with your values,
with your,
with your purpose and so that that demolishes the values from facts argument.
Now it makes it complicated because there's an interrelationship between like a
causal interrelationship,
but it is the case that your purpose determines the facts that are themselves
before you and that's actually not disputable.
I would say there's a fact saw the actual fact on actual factors that have six
books and actual fact is that there's a infinite,
if you will,
way in which the order them,
and if I were to divide this would be in a photo.
So the fact all they were my values introduced is how I'm gonna order them.
But what the call or even if their book,
but no,
the bullfighter what they might be firewood.
They might be a weapon.
Yeah.
There's lots of things they can be other than books
for the physical.
So amusing to me because the first,
no,
seriously though,
the first,
uh,
I study and I've written quite a bit on content formation and classification,
but whenever I'm writing,
but I don't think I've ever said this before.
Um,
I remember back to when I was a little kid and I had this bookshelf and I was
ordering the books on the bookshelf and I was thinking,
well,
what's the right way to do it?
Uh,
and of course the answer is there isn't one right way built into nature.
Here's how everyone's got to put into the Dewey decimal system.
And if not for Dewey,
no one would've figured it out.
Right.
There are,
um,
a lot of examples,
a lot of different ways you can order books,
but there are all and anything else,
right.
But there are all sorts of problems about the things that,
um,
make it necessary to order them in certain ways to achieve different purposes.
Right.
Uh,
and to understand that as long as you add that last part,
there's very broad types of we have to have in order to be able to think and
function at all.
Yeah.
Um,
and those purposes,
the purpose of getting to know as much of reality as we can of holding that
reality in a way that won't Flomex us.
And therefore with unity,
economical is the word.
Um,
ran sometimes you just for this,
so a way that allows you to hold a lot of information in a compact number of
units.
Um,
and then there are certain facts that you need to know.
And other facts we don't because of our natures,
you know,
to navigate ourselves through the world provides standards for how we are
conceptualizing.
Yeah.
So although our purposes and our needs as human beings matter,
it's not as though any purpose is just as good as any other.
And there's a,
well,
you can come up with standards for objectivity of what,
um,
what is an objective way to form concepts and declassify in the same way that
you can come up with standards for what?
Waiting.
I agree with everything you said,
except I don't think you can come up with it objectively.
I even think there is a hierarchy of values though.
Hey,
listen to the objective though that's involved in objective grading or objective
reporting,
right?
It's not that the grades are already out there in the paper and you just got to
find it in there or the newspaper stories already written in a good reporter
will find it.
It's rather there's a way,
maybe not just one,
but a small range of them right away,
that this has to be done in order to accomplish legitimate purposes for doing
it.
Yes.
There's a finite range of organizing things that will enable you to use them in
a in a reasonable way.
We mean,
when we talk about an article being written,
objective Lee,
a paper being graded objectively,
and I think in the same sense,
you can talk about a concept being formed subjectively or values being formed
objective,
but okay.
Right?
[inaudible] there's a lot in that
that I think is,
is,
is dead on.
Like I do believe,
for example,
that one of the ways we deal with the fact that there's a plethora of facts is
that we impose interpretive structures on those facts that are common to all of
us because we have common goals,
like we don't want to suffer and die.
Generally speaking,
we want to stay alive and our biological systems predispose us to act in ways
that are commensurate with that.
And,
and so I don't think there's an infinite number of solutions to the fact that
there's an infinite number of problems.
That's where I think the postmodern,
this have gone wrong.
But I think that when you say that what you've produced by by constraining the
solution set is somehow akin to objectivity that that's where I have a
conceptual problem.
Even though I don't disagree with the reason that you would make that case.
Then I guess what would happen is we'd have to define what constitutes objective
because when I think of objective,
I think about the strict application of the scientific method and what that's
done for us is lay out a world,
not a values,
but of objective fats.
If you're objective,
you can lay out the objective facts,
but I can't see how you can derive the damn values.
Even though I do believe that there's a hierarchy of values and that there's a
finite hierarchy.
I don't think putting that into the category of objective truth is reasonable
because I don't think that those truths are objective.
There's some,
there's,
there's some other form of truth.
Well,
and I think that that's generally captured in something like metaphor and
narrative,
which I think Dave's going to push us to move on in a minute,
but I want to think one thing.
If I can before I actually wasn't,
I was thinking that maybe we dumped the Q and a and just keep going.
Wow.
You wanted to say about,
I mean,
so first I totally agree up one of these fully dump it.
We'll,
we'll do about 10 more here.
One of the that you did,
how do we define objectivity and is another one of these classifying questions,
right?
Uh,
and that's an interesting question.
Where did this concept come from?
There's a whole history to it.
There've been books written about the history of the concept of creativity and
that's something maybe for another occasion,
but let's flag that as a really interesting question.
As for just want to say something about his art before we,
and also something about whether we can get to the same conclusion starting from
different places.
Um,
I see what Harris is doing is he's in the tradition of a lot of impurities to
goes back to epic.
Heareth it's definitely present in mill and then a different kind of way in
Hume.
Um,
they'll very different in Hume and Adam Smith.
if you're an empiricist,
do you think everything comes from perception and you usually have a kind of
fairly atomized view of perception.
Think that collections of confessions and what these types of impurities
generally do when they get to ethics is they pick some sensation to identify
their value terms with.
So either pain,
maybe the sensation of pain is indicative suffering if the one sandy right is
the bad,
and then whatever the opposite to that pleasure with the good.
Some of them you the sensation of desire,
fulfillment or,
but they picked some sensation from simple psychological state that can be
experienced in a moment and identify that with the good.
And then they come up with some theory about,
you know,
how do we get as many of those moments through as much of them as possible.
That famously with John Stuart mill does epicure with in a very different way.
Um,
and if you think you can derive value from facts like that,
I don't,
I think that's the mistake.
I don't even think that's really deriving value from that.
All that's doing is identifying value with certain very,
very simple fat.
So what I think the real question about deriving value from fact is,
is we have the value concepts,
concepts like good and bad that we use to direct ourselves,
directors hell through life.
How do we form vive concepts and these concepts be formed based on fat in an
objective manner as opposed to just being found out there already or um,
or just being made up and you can make up your worth and I can make up mine.
And there's no way to tell if the Nazis or the Klu Klux Klan or the communists
to where we are right about what the value.
So,
um,
so I think we have to take this question back to the broader question of how do
you form concepts and what kind of ways,
just perceptual evidence play in the forming of feather.
And in the case of value concept,
and here I'm drawing on rand if I usually do.
Um,
what I think we do is at the deepest level,
it comes from the needs of living organisms.
There were certain ways they need to function in order to survive and prosper
and values or the way that we conceptualize that there'd be conceptually.
So a human values in health and conceptual form is an identification of
something a human being needs to live.
And he values that in so far as he chooses to live.
And in some foreign recognizes that it will contribute to his life.
But what I think ethics is a branch of philosophy as a science and in fact has
to do,
is really articulate the foundations of the values,
where they come from,
what the fundamental values are,
what the fundamental ways of achieving them is.
So how would you ask
perspective from the perspective of our Darwinian pragmatist?
So let me just say one more thing before I get to that.
So,
but that doing that as a philosopher is a pretty sophisticated thing.
People don't start doing philosophy until thousands of years more than that into
living as human being.
This particular theory of the origin of values didn't come about until the
1950s.
So in some sense,
prior to that,
human beings,
we're identifying things as values in conceptual terms.
We learn it as we were kids.
We learned that some things are good and some things are bad.
And what a philosophical theory of values has meant to do is to articulate why
that works,
what it is that we're doing that or when we do that.
But other people who don't have the same theory than us,
we'll have some of the same values.
And so we might come to the same conclusions,
but without being able to fully defend and articulate them in the same as,
I don't think it's coincidence that both of us sync,
the Nazis were bad and the communists were bad.
Uh,
even though we start in some sense from different places,
but I think to fully develop and understand what's bad about them,
uh,
and to come out consistently on the more difficult cases,
of what's good and bad.
Although the Nazis was a really difficult case for a lot of people we should
remember in the communist still is.
That's where we need I think to get down to the donors know you're asking me
about the Darwinian.
Yep.
Well,
because you know,
if,
if you're,
if you're making the claim,
which I think is,
it's a,
it's a justifiable claim,
whether or not it's accurate,
um,
is that our ethics are grounded in something like the necessary,
we could say the necessity for survival and reproduction,
which are variants of survival.
Obviously it's a Darwinian claim.
It's the claim that the American pragmatists advanced as well because this is,
this is,
um,
person and um,
William Jameson primarily,
you know,
they believe that you're,
your knowledge was a tool.
Knowledge was a tool to advance being in the world,
let's say survival in the world and that you justified your knowledge not
because you had finite final knowledge of anything,
but because your tools were good enough to obtain the end that you were aiming
at.
That was the validation process.
If your theory was good enough to get you to where you are aiming,
that it's,
it was true enough and the pragmatists believed that that was the best that you
could do with truth.
And then when Darwin advanced his theory,
the American pragmatist said,
Oh look,
Darwin's theory is actually an extension of pragmatism.
And pragmatism is the notion that your truths are good enough to facilitate your
survival.
But this is the rub is that star wars,
there's a,
there's a truth that's embedded in the Darwin you'd worldview that is not the
same truth that is embedded in the Newtonian worldview.
There's a conflict between those two.
And the Newtonian worldview is basic,
basically the world of fat,
right?
Roughly speaking.
And there's a,
there's a set of claims about truth that are based in a Newtonian worldview and
they're not the same as the ones that are based in the Darwinian point of view.
It's a big problem.
And part of the reason that I've been arguing with Sam for like three years is
because he's an evolutionary psychologist in principle and a by a biological
thinker.
And yet he essentially has a Newtonian worldview that is the world of facts.
That's real.
It's like,
no,
no.
There's a world of values and the world of values is devoted not towards
determining what's objectively true but towards facilitating survival.
And those are not the same thing.
Now there's obviously a relationship between them because the world of values
and the world of facts coexists,
but the relationship doesn't seem to be one to one.
Got It.
I mean the will,
the will the values just use a valuer that is the wall.
The fact they are facts out there.
The that's the Newtonian physics.
They really is a world out there.
The all of it values exist here,
exist in the mind of individuals.
We value something.
It's,
there are no values out there independent out of value work.
So these are two different dimensions and any,
any,
any work,
you know,
they,
part of valuing is identifying the fact,
yes,
this is the rub.
That's funny.
Probably even used your hand motions.
[inaudible] we did.
I mean the,
the American pragmatists are interesting philosophically and,
and there were some things I like about them and one is the really stressed the
importance of activity and thought,
you know,
thought you don't just,
the world doesn't just come to,
you have to do something,
uh,
to think right.
If physically the they really stressed the activity of the mind and they really
stress the role of ideas in action.
And I think that's something that's left out in a lot of philosophy.
But I think they lose the reality in doing that.
So they treat it as though,
um,
consciousness is just something that uh,
running your life and all your ideas or just what your mind busy doing.
But I think what we know and can tell to be the case when we just introspect on
our own conscious and think about what it is to be conscious is that to be
conscious,
to be conscious of something,
to be conscious of something independent of yourself.
There's a world out there and what we mean by consciousness is the graph above
and awareness of that world.
We wouldn't even be able to get the idea of our own consciousness except
contrast to a world that we're distinguishing it from.
You close your eyes and you open them and you think the things still there.
You know,
you have the idea that of a world that's there and then your consciousness is of
that world.
And I think you have to have that idea of knowledge and knowledge being about
something that's independent of you.
Um,
and I think the pragmatists lose that.
I think there's this kind of dichotomy we find in thought between everything's
in your head and your,
your mind is very active in your knowing the world and you're deciding things
and therefore you don't actually get out the world the way it actually is.
And then on the other side,
you do get out the world the way it actually is.
But because you don't do anything,
it just comes to you passive.
And I think both of those are wrong.
There's activity you have to do to get at the world,
but it's activity to get at the way the world is.
And of course you get it in a certain form.
Just like if I kicked something up,
I'm holding it in one form and I could hold it in a different form,
you know?
But I'm still holding it.
It's not like I'm getting any.
And likewise for values.
Dogmatists do retain the world,
but they look at it slightly different.
They say the world is what objects to your stupid theory.
So let's say you,
you,
so it's not that the world is made of objects.
The world is made of what objects to your stupid theory.
That's a whole different idea.
And it's a way more sophisticated idea.
And so for the pragmatists,
if you lay out a theory in the world in action and the action obtains its,
and then the theory is sufficiently true,
but you know,
lots of times when you lay out your theory in the world,
you don't get what you expected.
And then the question is what you get.
And you might say,
well,
you get an array of new facts.
It's like,
no,
that's not what happens.
What you do,
what you get is an array of new incomprehensible possibilities and that's not
the same thing as a set of facts.
So let me give you an example.
You'll all understand this very rapidly.
Imagine you're married to someone and you trust them and they betray you and you
discover that one day.
So that's the world objecting to your stupid theory,
that's for sure.
Because you had a theory about who you were and the theory about who your
partner was in the theory about what your life was and that theory was seriously
wrong.
Past,
present,
and future are all something radically new.
You might say,
well,
a new set of facts confronts you really?
Is that right?
Okay,
just what are those facts?
It's like you'll be in a pit for two or three years trying to just get the bare
facts out of that situation.
The only thing you'll know for sure when the world objects to your stupid theory
is that you were wrong.
It's not like the world is going to array.
It sets like who is this person that I was married to?
That's what's going to be the question.
And the question is,
what kind of fool was I for making these presuppositions to begin with?
And it's not like that new knowledge will manifest itself in a set of instantly
apprehensible facts about the true nature of the world.
You're going to be suffering like mad for a very good long time before you can
take what you have,
which isn't facts,
but just confusion and transform that into something that's even vaguely
resembling a set of apprehensible facts.
You'll be in serious psychological trouble until the world reveals itself as a
set of apprehensible facts.
And if you're traumatized badly enough,
it'll never happen.
And so that's another part of the problem with the idea that the world just
represents itself as facts from which you can derive values.
It's like not when you're bloody confused and you're confused a lot and you're,
you're confused when the range of potential that's manifested exceeds your,
your,
your grasp exceeds your capabilities and then the way you respond to that isn't
even cognitively the way you respond to that.
This is part of embodied cognition.
What do you do when something in comprehensible objects to you?
Well,
it depends on how incomprehensible it is,
but let's say what did you do when the twin towers fell was at this set of
facts?
It's like you didn't know what the hell was going on and neither did anyone
else.
What you did was go into a state of crisis and that state of crisis is actually
an embodied pre-cognitive response and what happens biologically is that you get
flooded with cortisol,
which is a stress hormone,
and what it does is prepare you to take a very large array of potential actions.
That's your response.
So it's not like the world has raid itself as a set of facts from which you can
derive value.
What happens is the world is the rate itself as an incomprehensible mystery and
you have to do something about that and what you do is ratchet up your
physiology so that you're burning yourself up because you age faster with this
sort of thing happens,
which is why you age faster.
If you're in crisis,
you burn yourself up in the attempt to do everything at once,
to prepare to do everything at once.
And that's really the world manifesting itself as an object and objecting to
your theory.
It doesn't come out as an array of facts.
It would be so lovely if every time you were wrong,
what happened was a new array of facts.
Yeah.
The point is,
the point is that the reality doesn't just show up.
It's not just an array of fact,
but when that cortisol happens,
when that if it happens,
what you do is consciously make an effort to go find the facts.
If
the facts are still in reality.
So something happened and I and 11 so the first thing you do is what actually
happened.
You have to figure out what actually happened is real work and real cognitive
effort.
Who are these people?
Well,
what is the ideology driving them?
Why did they do?
It's all of these things off facts that exist in reality at your responsibility,
your mom's responsibility,
I think to yourself is to go find and discover the facts that are relevant for
the decisions.
And the actions you need to take given the event that's happened.
So yes,
psychologically if you discover your wife from a train,
you,
you're confused.
But I think your job as a human being is,
okay,
what actually happened and where did I make my mistakes?
So it's hot,
but this is what you want to,
what free will is free will is that engaging reason,
engaging our consciousness to discover the facts out there and,
and apply them to making a new conclusion.
Right?
Okay,
so so something's wrong in my values and my wife,
what was it?
Did you really betray me?
Or the facts is it is what's going on here real.
So all of it is again of tune to reason or return to,
to return to the discovery of facts,
which is what,
what reason does.
Okay,
so two things.
First,
you mentioned relevant,
the relevant facts and that's the rub.
But I would also say interestingly enough in relationship to your argument that
developmental psychologists,
Sean Piaget made a very similar claim.
He said that because the domain of established facts was mutable and that's the,
that's the issue.
Say with the fact that your partner could be Trey,
you,
even what you know can be,
can be mutable,
right?
Then what is relevant in the search for truth isn't the search for a set of
immutable facts,
but a search for the process by which by which factor generated from the chaotic
potential to begin with.
It's not exactly how Piaget worded it,
but,
but the fact so that your wife is either between you,
if she's not betraying you,
it's not.
It's not.
There's this always a potential is also potentiality.
But she's either between you,
she's not betraying you and your job is to discover whether she is or she isn't,
right?
If that's the job you've assigned yourself.
Right?
So,
so it,
the fat,
the reality is what it is.
Uh,
it's not dependent on you'll discovering it or not.
Your responsibility if you're married is,
is to know whether your wife is between you and not.
Uh,
hopefully,
hopefully you don't need to do the exercise cause,
uh,
cause she's not in,
in,
and,
and you have trust in that.
But,
but your consciousness is identifying the truth of what's out there.
It's not,
some are way of infinite possibility.
She could be betraying,
she'd be half betrayed you.
She can be happy to train you just like she can't be half pregnant.
So the two possibilities,
she says the a you she's not.
And your job is to apply reason,
which I take as identifying what is true and what is not,
what is factual and what is not,
what is the evidence weighing the evidence.
And then there's a whole,
a psychological assessment of the why did this happen to me?
What did I see?
Did I screw up that she screw up?
Why he was my assessment before?
But that's a separate question.
First,
did she,
had she,
so,
so it strikes me as just this is relatively simple,
right?
If the facts are what they are,
our job is to discover them and let me know.
Let me
say about this,
the world objecting to your theory.
Uh,
it's certainly true that the world of jets to stupid theory if you've got them
to try it out.
But I don't take that as a definition of the world if one fact about the world,
uh,
and more importantly the fact about our theories that they better match the
world.
Otherwise we are going to have trouble with them.
And when you get into this situation,
and this is what I,
the pragmatists take it too often as though the theory is just there were not
too interested in how it got there except by repeated episodes of what's about
to happen,
which is that the world objects to it.
And then you go scrambling to try to get out of this state of cognitive
dissonance that you're in because of the objection.
So,
you know,
um,
do,
he says at one point thought thoughts of disease,
right?
Everything's easy and nice.
You don't have to think,
you just go by in some stupid,
he wouldn't put it that way.
But,
uh,
and then some fact objects and now you've where the world objects and now you've
in dissonance and you've got to figure out how to reconfigure your mental life
so that you can get on with it.
And that is what a lot of people did after nine 11 right?
A lot of people,
something unexpected and horrible happened and what they were motivated to do
was figure out what are the fewest moves I can make to get things to go back to
normal and be all right.
I don't care what's true.
I don't care who really did this.
I don't care what would really solve it.
I just care what I can tell myself to make this confusion and disruption and
agitation go away and that's dishonesty and that's wrong.
And to really value honesty and wanting to get the right answer and being
rational in these situations and caring about what happens to your damn life.
You can't say,
you know,
Oh,
I just want to be back into blissful oblivion by coming up with some new theory.
Why do y'all know what went wrong in the first place?
I got to this theory somehow.
Yup.
Uh,
now I see that the theory is wrong.
What mistake did I make along the way?
What was the process by which I generated this Siri?
And what was the misstep in that process?
How can I fix it to generate a new theory,
one that'll be true.
And that that process by which you generate your theories,
it's a process of forming concepts.
It's a process of collecting evidence.
It's a complicated process.
It's a lot to say about it,
right?
Sounds like repentance and atonement to me.
Uh,
it can be,
but it's in that you're acknowledging an error and you're trying to fix it,
but you're trying to see how you made this theory and how you can make it
better.
And if you,
this idea that,
you know,
this idea,
that philosophy and really thinking starts when you come to contradictions,
you get this back in the Greek was the dialectical tradition and people debating
each other.
And I think there's something really profound in Aristotle,
uh,
as opposed to Plato and the other Greeks,
the other Greeks,
they seem to,
and then later Hago they come up with contradictions and they think what can we
do to get past this contradiction?
But what Aristotle always does and all of his books have this structure.
I think it's brilliant.
He,
he gets into a field by discussing the debates in it.
He shows all the contradictions and all the puzzles and it can't be this and
this,
and then he says,
let's start fresh.
Let's go back to the drawing board.
Let's think about how we got here.
And then he crafts a new theory starting from the pint of fact that motivated
the old series from the kind of observations,
let's say that motivated the old theory,
but that avoids the difficulties in the new one.
Rather than just trying to reconfigure the go forward,
you go back and if there's a hierarchy,
not just the hierarchy of values but also a hierarchy of our understanding of
the world,
certain ways of understanding it or more basic and others that are built up on
top of that.
When you find that one of your theories and the theories are really complex way
of knowing,
right?
When you find that one of your theories is mistaken,
you think,
how can I go back to the more basic,
more primitive types of knowledge?
Uh,
more basic types of observations,
whatever it might be from which I generated this Siri and then and now add to it
the new observations and the new knowledge that I have based on what went
wrong and generate a new theory that will be better than it.
Yeah.
Let's give Jordan the last word on that as well.
Yes,
but
the problem is,
you know,
that works.
There's,
there's two problems with it though.
One is that it's really,
really,
really difficult cognitively because the more of your theory you have to unpack,
like imagine that your theory is composed of presumptions and the more basic
that presumption,
the more your world is organized as a consequence of that presumption.
And so like the presumption of your partner's fidelity is a very fundamental
presumption because the entire interpretation of your relationship is predicated
on that assumption.
And so if you let that assumption go,
then you let everything that you know about your relationship go and that casts
you into chaos more and more thoroughly.
So the more you go back to first principles to revise your theory,
the more cognitive,
I don't like this distance idea,
but the more you throw your state yourself into a state of existential crisis
and the more you end up cycle physiologically preparing for catastrophe as a
consequence and the faster you die.
So the problem with ungluing things back down to first principles,
which is actually what happens to people by the way when they develop post
traumatic stress disorder,
is that you undo yourself in doing that.
And when you undo yourself,
there's a physiological price to pay.
So even though that is the root out make a fundamental error,
you should make fundamental reparations.
The cost of doing that is unbelievably high.
And so people are loath to do it even though they might have to do it because of
course,
you know,
you were saying it was wrong to paper over an error.
And I asked what?
Why is it wrong?
If it makes you feel better,
why is it wrong?
Which is a perfectly good question.
But the answer to why it's wrong is what?
What do you want to make the same stupid error again?
What if the air was caused I fatal?
You make it two more times your dad.
And so the cost of repeating,
that's the thing about cognitive errors insofar as they are enacted.
If there are errors and you make them in the world,
the world objects and it takes you apart,
and if there is profound enough,
then you suffer a lot and die.
And maybe not just you.
Like the errors can be really profound.
So it might be that you have to fix the damn hole in your map because otherwise
you'll fall through.
But that nonetheless,
that the cost of doing that is so high that you're going to shy away from it.
And people do that all the time.
That's partly why they take the easy route.
It's like they take the easy route because the difficult route is,
it's difficult.
It's really difficult.
Well,
think about what you'd have to figure out if you were subject to a betrayal like
that.
It's like,
well,
maybe you married the wrong person.
That's possible.
Maybe you created the wrong person in your marriage,
in your interactions,
interactions with your partner.
Or maybe you're so damn naive that it's just absolutely beyond comprehension.
Like there's all sorts of terrible things lurking under the revelation
of that objection.
And digging down there to,
to,
to pull them out is it's a hell of a job,
right?
That's the confrontation with the terrible dragon of chaos.
And in that confrontation,
you can easily be burnt to a crisp.
Oh,
so,
but this is partially why it's so,
it's so crucial to know yourself and to build a solid foundation of self,
uh,
in any relationship.
Right?
So that,
so that it's not somebody else's betrayal does not unwind everything you think
about yourself.
So you can't go that every time reality doesn't match your theory,
you completely unlined.
Right?
Right.
So,
so knowing oneself,
having a solid foundation as sense of you know,
sense of self esteem,
a sense of self worth or self sense of confidence and,
and having a philosophical foundation and this is why as you said,
it's hard work.
And that week we completely,
that is morality is hardwork living is hard work.
Uh,
you went back to,
to the idea of,
of the pragmatism and survival.
One of the things that,
that we,
you know,
that I hold it,
we hold I think is that survival call human being as a human being with their
unique features as human being is a lot of work.
And they were quite particular type of work,
particularly reasoning and thinking and figuring stuff out.
And the more work we do,
the more we build our character,
the easier it is to deal with the shocks to the system.
The easier it is to deal with the nine 11 or more betrayal because we know where
we are and now we just need to figure out what the facts on we can deal with
whatever the facts of whatever we already throws at you.
If you've done the Malo work to create a moral character you should be able to
deal with while you have your been
up.
[inaudible]
I got a seriously stiff neck from looking that way the whole time.
Sorry guys.
How you doing over there?
What happens up left?
Yeah.
Whoo.
Um,
well this was such a perfect example of why I love the reality that I like to
think I created and maybe some of it came from before me
would be good.
This is it.
[inaudible]
I mean,
what do you think was more worthwhile?
What we just did here for an hour or what was on CNN for the last hour?
You know,
this really is it.
And you know,
these are,
these are huge differences and in,
and in some ways they're small differences.
And that's what I want to end for our final five minutes here is why is it that
so seemingly these days,
so few people are willing to do this.
So few people are willing to tour the country to talk all to all sorts of people
about all sorts of different things and put their ideas on the line and,
and do all the philosophical work that you do and you're on,
you travel the world
and it seems there's an absolute starvation for it.
And yet,
so few people are doing it.
You're on,
I'll start with you and then we'll go this way.
Well,
I mean,
I think because those people who don't want to have the debate have no ideas
[inaudible] really empty.
Uh,
then he lists in some cases.
And in that case,
what does kneelers them,
Neil Isms,
they absence.
It's zero away.
I mean,
I think called it the worship of zero,
right?
It's a nothingness.
It's,
it's,
it's the,
they don't stand for anything.
Whether you're going to go and do debates when they don't really represent
anything other than destruction.
There's nothing to talk.
Reason doesn't matter.
Ideas don't matter.
The speech doesn't matter.
If as a consequence of what matter is action,
this is why on Tifo storms into your room and you know,
they,
they use their fists.
They,
there's nothing for them to say.
There's no value that they have to present.
And I think it's true on if you will,
on,
on the,
uh,
on the rights,
on the,
on the non speech,
right?
It's the same thing.
It's my revelation,
my verbal,
you know,
Islam or Christianity or whatever the religion is.
It's my revelation.
It's not heated debates.
The truth was revealed to me.
You know,
there's no logic,
there's no reason.
There's no rationality that can challenge the fact that God spoke to me through
a book or whatever.
The way he spoke to me,
and this is the truth and there's nothing else that can be discussed.
So you've got two sides.
All they have is emotion and action.
Reason,
ideas,
debate,
discussion.
As soon as you abandoned reason.
As soon as you abandoned the idea,
that conversation,
that logic is the way in which we debate,
discuss and discover the truth,
then now you've abandoned speech,
right?
So they are against free speech because they're against reason because they're
against reality.
They're there.
So that really the beauty of this,
it's not that there has to be a knockout here that somebody has to be,
you know,
dragged off stage is that everyone,
although wait for the closer
we're going to be,
but what that really that everyone here,
the 600 some odd people here can take what they've heard here and then start
applying their own logic and reason and figure out what what they believe.
Totally think and say to my students in that connection is that it'll minds the
rarely changed in the course of an argument.
That doesn't mean they're not changed by an argument.
But you know,
if you and I are having an argument now,
it's about something important in deep.
It's very unlikely that one of us at the end of the 15 minutes,
we're arguing he's going to come away with a changed world view.
It happens occasionally,
but pretty rare.
But often,
you know,
you go home,
you think about it.
I think about it in both of us improve our thinking as a result of that.
And maybe sometimes you see profound changes over time.
The other thing I want it to say to your comment about why don't we see more of
this,
a wire and people willing to go around the country and do these kinds of talks
and um,
and it does seem like there's a hunger for it.
People are turning out.
Um,
yeah.
One
important thing with products and,
and uh,
you know,
this is a product that we're creating here,
right?
For people to consume is there's a lot of times in the world when there is a
potential demand for a product and people who could create that product and
nobody notices it and it goes a long time with nobody knows at the end.
What's,
what's great about entrepreneurs is they're the kinds of people who noticed that
there's an opportunity for them.
They figure it out and they create something new.
And I think that's what you're doing here,
right?
You probably would have been willing to go on a tour a couple of years ago.
Um,
and you know,
you're onboard.
We,
um,
but before it was proven that there were these people who want to hear this and
there are ways to connect them together.
Nobody would have known to do it.
And so what all of you guys are doing in this connection,
and particularly Dave,
what you're doing and bringing all these people together on these long form talk
shows,
I think is fantastic.
And it's creating this kind of value.
And I see it as one of the things that one of the hopeful signs in the culture
that combating the fines that you were on talked about on both political sides.
[inaudible]
can either take us out softer,
go for the kill,
because
they're a very friendly group of people.
Look,
I mean,
if you're gonna talk about,
if you're going to dare to think publicly about difficult things to think and
speak publicly about difficult things,
then you're going to cause trouble because you can't talk about something
difficult without causing trouble.
If it was easy,
then everyone would agree and then you could talk about it.
No one would care because everyone already knew.
But it would be easy.
But if it's difficult and you talk about it,
then you're going to upset people.
And then when you upset people,
they're gonna yell at you a lot and then well that's what's going to happen.
And then you know,
if you're not sure that there's any support for your position or even if you're
sort of vaguely human ended,
upsets you to be yelled at by many,
many people,
you know,
you tend to shut up if a whole bunch of people that are yelling at you,
because you might be wrong.
And also you might be in danger.
But,
but what happens right now is that,
well two things.
One thing to know is that just because some people yell at you right now,
it doesn't mean that all people will yell at you over the next month.
Right?
So the people who are being thoughtful about it are going to be quieter and they
might be sort of hiding in the woodwork.
And so you have to learn that.
But then the other thing is,
and we've talked about this quite a bit in this tour,
is that there's a technological revolution that's occurring that's enabling
these long form conversations.
And it wasn't possible before.
Like we can live stream this right for no cost.
And so a whole bunch of people can watch this and the technology's there,
and it turns out that the technology has revealed to us the fact that there's a
collective starvation for deep,
long form discussion.
And so hurray for that.
And so maybe that niche will be increasingly filled.
It's,
it seems to be happening.
And so,
um,
and that would be a good,
because it seems to me that the way out of our current state of idiot political
polarization is,
isn't the final establishment that one side is right and the other is wrong,
but to engage in sophisticated long form discussions to deal with the actual
problems that are producing the polarization.
And maybe we can do that.
And maybe this is part of the process by which we do that successfully.
That would be a testament to the utility of the reason that you were describing,
which is the only alternative to subjugation or violence,
right.
We either talk it through,
we can pitch your late or we tyrannized those are the options.
So
[inaudible] on that note,
going for talking it through and for these three guys who presented there,
right?
Yes.
Thank you guys for coming out.
Thank you for watching on the Youtube [inaudible].